FOX ALSO FACES THE VERY REAL
POSSIBILITY OF LAWSUITS FROM
SHAREHOLDERS, WHICH WILL EXPLAIN
MORE ABOUT IN A MOMENT PREFERS
FORMER FOX ANCHOR GRETCHEN
CARLSON, WHO REACHED A $20
MILLION SETTLEMENT WITH FOX'S
PARENT COMPANY AFTER ALLEGING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
RETALIATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US. THANKS FOR
HAVING ME YOU SURPRISED BY THE
SETTLEMENT. NO I WAS SURPRISED
THAT IT WENT ON AS LONG AS IT
DID IN UP TO UP TO DATE OF THE
TRIAL. I'M NOT A LAWYER. I DID
TAKE THE L SETS, BUT I FEEL LIKE
I'M SORT OF A HALF LAWYER AFTER
EVERYTHING I'VE BEEN THROUGH AND
THE ONE THING YOU LEARN IS THAT
YOU SHOULD NEVER PUT YOUR CEO S
OR C SUITE EXECUTIVES UNDER
DEPOSITION, UNLESS YOU'RE PRETTY
SURE THAT YOU HAVE A SOLID CASE
, SO I WAS REALLY SURPRISED THAT
THEY ALLOWED ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION AND MIS TRUTHS TO BE
ABLE TO GO PUBLIC. WHY DO YOU
THINK THEY ULTIMATELY SETTLED?
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THEY SAW
THE WRITING ON THE WALL. THE
JUDGE HAD SEVERAL RULINGS DURING
HEARINGS THAT WERE NOT IN THEIR
FAVOR, AND IT COULD HAVE ALSO
BEEN THE MAKEUP OF THE JURY.
REMEMBER THE JURY WAS SEATED,
AND MAYBE THEY DIDN'T LIKE WHAT
THEY SAW, AND ALSO, I THINK THAT
THEY OBVIOUSLY DID NOT WANT
THEIR TOP HOSTS TO BE COMING AND
BE MEDIA FODDER FOR FIVE OR SIX
WEEKS UNDER OATH THAT IDEA OF
DAY AFTER DAY, SEEING A TUCKER
CARLSON OR SEAN HANNITY OR
WHOMEVER TRAIPSING ONTO THE
WITNESS STAND. WELL, EXACTLY.
AND YOU KNOW, IT WOULD BE AN
INTERESTING PLACE. I'M SURE
MEDIA COVERAGE WOULD HAVE BEEN
MASSIVE. AND I'M SURE ALL MEDIA
OUTLETS WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE
SEEN THAT. BUT BUT YOU KNOW,
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE
FIRST TIMES THAT THOSE
PARTICULAR HOSTS WOULD HAVE TO
BE UNDER OATH AND ACTUALLY
TELLING THE TRUTH. THERE WILL BE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THERE WASN'T
AN APOLOGY. FROM FOX. AT FIRST I
WAS AND I THINK I TWEETED OUT ON
MONDAY NIGHT, YOU SAID. PLEASE,
DOMINION. DO NOT SETTLE WITH
FOX. YOU'RE ABOUT TO APPROVE
SOMETHING VERY BIG. WHY DID YOU
HOPE THAT THEY WEREN'T THAT
DOMINION WASN'T GOING TO SAY
SOMEBODY WHO'S ALSO HAD A VERY
HIGH PROFILE LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
FORMER CEO AND CHAIRMAN OF FOX
NEWS, ROGER AILES AS SOMEBODY
WHO'S BEEN SILENCED AS A RESULT
OF THAT, WITH BEING ABLE TO TELL
ALL THE FACTS OF WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED TO ME. YOU KNOW, I WAS
VICARIOUSLY LIVING THROUGH
DOMINION AND HOPING THAT THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET TO THE
TRUTH OF PEOPLE WERE A LOT OF
OBSERVERS WHO ARE NOT. FANS OF
FOX WERE WANTING THAT. UM AND
YEAH, DOMINION IS A CORPORATION
. THEY HAVE SHAREHOLDERS. THEY
HAVE A PARENT COMPANY FROM A
FINANCIAL SENSE. THAT CERTAINLY
MAKES SENSE. IT'S TOTALLY
DIFFERENT THAN MY CASE. YOU
KNOW, I ACTUALLY DID GET AN
APOLOGY. AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT I HOLD CLOSE TO MY HEART
EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT I THINK
ABOUT IT BECAUSE SO MANY
SURVIVORS WERE LIVING THROUGH ME
. WHEN I GOT THAT APOLOGY, IT'S
A VALIDATION. UM IT'S HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE AND IT RARELY
HAPPENS. AND SO FOR ME, THAT WAS
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT
HAPPENED. IN MY CASE. I THINK IN
THIS CASE I DON'T THINK IT
REALLY WOULD HAVE MATTERED TO
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE TRYING TO
REACH TO CHANGE THEIR HEARTS AND
MINDS WHO ARE LOYAL VIEWERS OF
FOX WHO BELIEVE WHAT TUCKER
CARLSON WHO BELIEVE THAT SEAN
HANNITY OR EVEN IF THEY HAD TO
GO ON SET AND GIVE A 22ND
APOLOGY. IN THE ERA THAT WE LIVE
IN NOW A FAKE NEWS AND BELIEVING
ONLY WHAT YOU WANT TO BELIEVE. I
WOULD ASSUME THAT THE MAJORITY
OF THOSE VIEWERS WOULDN'T
BELIEVE THE APOLOGY ANYWAY. DO
YOU THINK THERE WILL BE ANY
REPERCUSSIONS FOR? I MEAN, LOOK
, THERE'S NOT GONNA BE A
REPERCUSSION FOR SEAN HANNITY.
TUCKER CARLSON. THEY HAVE VERY
BIG RATINGS. FOX NEWS IS GOING
TO BE BEHIND THEM. BUT FOR YOU
KNOW, THE MORE LOW HANGING FRUIT
OF LOU DOBBS AND RITA BARTIROMO
. DOBBS ALREADY MET HIS FATE. HE
WAS HE WAS LET GO. NOT A VIEWER.
SO YOU'RE RIGHT. YES I'M NOT
EITHER ANYMORE REALIZED. YES I
HAVE. I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA
. I MEAN, ONE MIGHT EXPECT IT.
BUT THEN WHY DID THEY ALLOW IT
TO GO THIS FAR TO BEGIN WITH?
DOES I MEAN I DON'T WANT TO GET
YOU INTO THE MIDDLE OF
SOMETHING, BUT THE MARIA
BARTIROMO HER BEHAVIOR DURING
ALL OF THIS WHAT SHE SAID ON AIR
HER HOSTING OF SIDNEY POWELL. IT
IS REALLY I MEAN IT JUST
JOURNALISTICALLY. IT'S SHAMEFUL.
UM. DID THAT SURPRISE YOU? I
MEAN, SHE I DON'T KNOW HER
PERSONALLY, I DON'T. I WAS ON
JEOPARDY WITH HER ONCE AND MY
GOSH, SHE DID NOT DO WELL, BUT I
HAS SHE WAS SHE ALWAYS LIKE THAT
. NOT THAT I RECALL, BUT I
CANNOT COMMENT ON THE PEOPLE
THAT I WORKED WITH.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF MY
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENT, BUT AS
FAR AS BEING SURPRISED ABOUT IT
, YOU KNOW, LOOK, I THINK THAT
SOME OF THE FOX HOSTS ARE A
MICROCOSM OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IN THE MACROCOSM OF VIEWERS,
WHICH IS WE WATCH NEWS NOW IN
SILOS, AND WE ONLY WATCH WHAT WE
WANT TO HEAR. AND QUITE HONESTLY
, I BELIEVE THAT THAT CAN RUB
OFF ON THE HOST AS WELL. UM DO
YOU FORESEE ANY CHANGES? NO THIS
WILL MAKING ANYBODY FOR ANYBODY.
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS WILL
CHANGE. THE WAY FOX DOES NEWS.
AND. THEREFORE, I DON'T THINK IT
WILL CHANGE THE WAY VIEWERS VIEW
THEM. UM I KNOW THAT WHAT I'VE
DONE IN MY LIFE IN THE LAST 6.5
YEARS THAT MY CASE AGAINST FOX
WAS INCREDIBLY MEANINGFUL AND
I'VE TAKEN FULL ADVANTAGE OF
THAT TO MAKE MY LIFE PASSION
MEANINGFUL NOW IN THE WORK THAT
I'M DOING TO MAKE WORKPLACES
SAFER. UM AND SO THAT'S WHAT I
TRY TO FOCUS ON NOW IS THE
POSITIVE AND WAKING UP EVERY DAY
AND KNOWING THAT I'M PASSING
BIPARTISAN LEGISLATION, NOT ONCE
BUT TWICE LAST YEAR, UM YOUR
ORGANIZATION IS LIFT OUR VOICES
. AND YOU KNOW, I HAD AN
ARBITRATION CLAUSE IN MY
EMPLOYMENT CONTRACT. WHICH IF MY
LAWYERS HAD NOT BEEN ABLE TO
STRATEGICALLY COME UP WITH THE
IDEA OF SUING ROGER AILES
PERSONALLY, MY CASE WOULD HAVE
NEVER BEEN PUBLIC AND I WOULD
HAVE BEEN FORCED INTO THE SECRET
CHAMBER OF ARBITRATION WHERE
DECADES OF CASES LIKE THESE HAVE
BEEN GOING. IT'S A VICIOUS CYCLE
OF SILENCE, SO THE MERE FACT
THAT I WAS ABLE TO MAKE MY CASE
PUBLIC WAS HUGE, BECAUSE HOW DID
I KNOW THAT I WAS GOING TO BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN IGNITING AN
INTERNATIONAL MOVEMENT HAVE NOW
TAKEN THAT RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT MILLIONS OF OTHER
AMERICANS NEVER HAVE TO BE
SILENCED AGAIN. SO LAST MARCH
3RD. I WAS PROUD TO STAND WITH
THE PRESIDENT IN A BIPARTISAN
COALITION OF LAWMAKERS WHEN HE
SIGNED THE ENDING FORCED
ARBITRATION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT ACT,
MEANING THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
GO TO THE SECRET CHAMBER OF
ARBITRATION ANYMORE. AND EIGHT
MONTHS LATER, WE WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING THE
SPEAK OUT ACT SIGNED. WHICH
MEANS THAT YOU CAN NO LONGER
FORCE PEOPLE TO SIGN PRE DISPUTE
INDUS FOR SEXUAL MISCONDUCT WHEN
YOU SAW SOME OF THOSE DOCUMENTS
THAT THROUGH DISCOVERY DOMINION
GOD IN WHICH WHAT FOLKS WERE
SAYING ON AIR AND WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING PRIVATELY IN TEXT
MESSAGES TO EACH OTHER. DID
THAT. UH THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHAT WAS BEING SAID AND WHAT
THEY WERE ACTUALLY BELIEVING
TUCKER CARLSON, SAYING HE HATED
DONALD TRUMP AND CLEARLY NOT
SAYING THAT ON AIR DID THAT
SURPRISE, YOU KNOW? LOOK I THINK
THAT EVEN RUPERT MURDOCH SAID
THAT IT WAS ALL ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THEY WERE IN THE GREEN
AND KEEPING THINGS YOU KNOW,
MAKING MONEY FOR THEM? LOOK I
THINK IT'S A TRAVESTY. BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S ACTUALLY A THREAT TO
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY TO PROMOTE
THAT KIND OF MISINFORMATION. LET
ME BE CLEAR. THERE IS A HUGE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ESPOUSING
CONSERVATIVE VIEWPOINTS AND
HAVING AN INTELLECTUAL
CONVERSATION BETWEEN
CONSERVATIVES AND LIBERALS,
WHICH I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THERE'S A HUGE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THAT AND TELLING LIES TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC, AND THAT'S
WHERE WE HAVE NOW BECOME IN THE
EVOLUTION OF FOX NEWS, AT LEAST
WITH REGARD TO THE 2020 ELECTION
IN JANUARY, 6TH DO YOU THINK
WITH THIS NEXT ELECTION? DO YOU
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HEAR THOSE
SAME SAME WISE TOLD AGAIN. OH
GOSH, DEPENDS ON WHO THE
CANDIDATE IS, I THINK BUT I HAVE
I HAVE NO WAY OF PREDICTING
THAT. UM BUT I WOULD LOVE TO BE
ABLE TO REACH OUT TO ALL OF
THOSE FOX NEWS VIEWERS AND HOPE
THAT SOMEHOW WE COULD GET THEM
BACK INTO